in 2013 I bought the limited edition of
SimCity and although it took me a few
days to finally get into a server once I
did I was really enjoying it well that
was right up until my fire engines
glitched out and decided to drive round
and round in circles while half my town
burned to the ground I really liked city
building games and at the time I was
happy to take SimCity for what it was
and with all its faults right up until
my game broke since there wasn't much
else like it now that's changed with the
release of cities skylines a game that
is quite simply everything that SimCity
2013 should have been at a glance city
skylines looks a lot like SimCity in
fact if it wasn't so good we'd probably
be calling it a clone or direct ripoff
but developer colossal order have
seriously proved themselves but what is
it that makes it so good
right off the bat skylines is much
cheaper than SimCity costing just 30
bucks at launch and seemingly without
sacrificing much at all it also offers
an online mode from the get-go
whereas EA gave gamers the runaround by
saying they needed SimCity to be online
before eventually caving and adding an
offline mode although not before
alienating a lot of their players
skyline seems like it has a lot more
flexibility and room to grow compared to
SimCity thanks to an already thriving
mod community and more comprehensive
gameplay features which cater to those
of you who love micromanaging beyond
that city skyline simply feels more
alive and true to its promise of
simulating city life than SimCity in
skylines your citizens aren't weirdos
who go to work in a different place
every day and return to the home that's
closest to them like in SimCity they
have their own personal names
occupations homes cars and feelings okay
sometimes your citizens clip into cars
or a crosswalk that you can actually
watch the little dudes go about their
lives which is special in such an
expansive city builder they live and
die you can follow their lives from
childhood right up until the graveyard
hearse comes to pick up their corpse
they graduate from different levels of
school get jobs based on their level of
education and move out of their parents
house so long as the city you've built
lets them have all those opportunities
of course but it's not just about
building skylines lets you manage and
have control over your cities by
allocating districts and applying a
number of policies concerning lifestyle
services taxation and City Planning
these cover everything from compulsory
recycling and the recreational use of
weed to taxing the rich and banning pets
in order to keep your houses clean
policies can be applied to the town as a
whole or simply to districts and
everything you do causes a butterfly
effect of pros and cons to the rest of
your city on top of that the
possibilities for expanded gameplay
features are huge thanks to well
integrated mods and enormous map sizes
unlike other city builders skyline seems
happy to have you build a great big town
and keep on expanding although you start
on a plot of land whose size is similar
to the last Sim City you're pretty
quickly given the opportunity to buy
extra plots on all sides so you'll find
you're never short of room or unable to
make the city that you can see in your
head I mean if somebody can make grand
theft auto 5 Los Santos you can be
reassured that there aren't a lot of
size restrictions while the game might
not feature every city related item you
can dream of there is the constant
promise of new stuff thanks to the
in-game asset and map editor Steam
Workshop integration and the huge
community that's already there that said
city skylines doesn't have that
excellent Maxis soundtrack that
underpinned SimCity and like any good
city planning game you will have to fail
at least once until you can create a
town that doesn't just slowly burn money
until all of your citizens are dead or
weeping City skylines has a lot of
exciting potential and in just a week
the game has sold over 500,000 copies it
manages to be both accessible and
incredibly complex depending on how long
you've been playing through a map and
whether you're a fan of digging into the
specifics of
judgment that's just my opinion though
so be sure to let me know down in that
comment section what you think of cities
skylines and how you reckon it stacks up
to SimCity I'll catch you again next
week